it says my name is jacopo and i work in
flixbus in berlin science now four years
and today i'm going to talk to you about
some lessons that we learned about using
postgres or in general any relational
database
in a data science project that is in
production
so by production i mean that we have to
process a lot of data to give you an
idea in peak periods not during covet
but now and before
we have up to five tickets sold per
second um
we have to process this data at least
every day
and it must be fresh so we have to be
sure that we do not see all that
otherwise our results are wrong
what are we trying to do
essentially what my team does is we get
data from the past from the past years
and we see how many people did buy a
ticket for a given ride
between us
specific from and to stop and how much
did they pay and when did they buy the
ticket
given that we build a model we train a
model and we use it to predict how many
people would like to buy a ticket for
every ride in the future in general in
one year in the future for every
specific stop so as you can imagine is a
lot of data millions of predictions and
we recalculate it every day
with different imperial different models
but essentially it's a lot of data so we
have the problem of performance of
course because it's a lot of data and
can take a lot of time to process
and we have a problem of stability
because as we keep
adding more lines merging with more
companies changing the services or just
changing the infrastructure we have the
schema that keeps changing so we need to
deal with that
and we have to be very careful about
outages because as you can imagine this
kind of prediction so the prediction of
the demand is what we use to then
calculate the price which means that if
we don't calculate it one day we lose
money
pretty much so it has to be very
robust
so
today we are going to focus on the
database part of it so not how we do the
machine learning but specifically how we
read and write data on the database we
have lots of data so performance issues
may arise there are many python
libraries that you can use
you have many queries and you need to
keep track of how much time it will take
so
uh is the query stuck are they actually
running every ticket too much time
and we need to deal with schema changes
so you have new tables new columns or
data that is in a different format
this is going to be very specific for
our use case
which means we use a lot of historical
data if you don't then i probably don't
really care
and we have a mostly batch operations
like training and prediction
are generally running
in background so you don't really need a
specific time you just care about the
overall timing but we also have some web
apps so we let users internal users
alter the forecast so they can specify
that the forecast for sunday is higher
and lower than we predicted because
there is maybe a concert a strike some
event that we just cannot integrate in
our model
so humans can actually change it
and that means that we have to provide
web apps for that
and this is important because if we use
for example a columnar data storage like
redshift
that's a bit tricky to do it's possible
but ugly
so we need also some sort of punctual
access and operational access to our
system
we use python because we are at python
and otherwise we would be at rather
conference
and is because it's essentially the
easiest way to do data science at the
moment and postgres because is is
basically that's my opinion but it's
based on facts it's basically the best
database that you can have for free um
it's very it has a lot of functionality
it's very performant and this free open
source is nice
this is how usually companies do this
you have
an operational system so the system that
actually does your business in our case
is the shop where people buy the ticket
it can be an app or
a website and an app or whatever but
basically this is some system that has a
database which is
designed for operational usage which
means that you access always
you have usually a lot of concurrent
connections and each one reads or writes
a very small amount of databases usually
single roles so you have a very
you have a sort of rain of continuous
small operations and this is an
operational system
you care about very fresh data of course
but you don't care about historical data
then you have an etl so some operation
that runs usually overnight
which reads from the operational system
and writes the data into some database
like right shift of bigquery or vertica
if somebody uses that
that is able to um
allow analytical queries in a very uh
fast way so
you can easily perform something like a
group by your account on a lot of data
fast
and
it's not that good for operational
access but that's fine
also you can do some transformations so
you can do joins group i filters and get
data format it's nicer for analysis and
reports and also potentially machine
learning we don't do that
for a few reasons
the first is that we need fresh data so
we cannot access accept a nightly dump
we did in the past but now not anymore
we need
data that is pretty much real time
and to that we use kafka so
we have there is a tool called the video
which in case you don't know essentially
intercepts every operation that happens
on a mysql database
and detects every change that depends on
database and based on that it generates
an event on kafka so every time somebody
writes or updates a row on database you
get a
kafka event which is very simple to
parse
so what we do we
read from these kafka events and in real
time essentially we write the same
change on our database which is a
postgres database
this means that we end up with extra
copy of the monolith database of the
operational database
the problem with doing that is that
we essentially cannot do any etl we have
an extra copy so we can
choose the tables that we want that we
can do we can choose the columns we can
do some stuff like
changing a time zone but that's it we
cannot do
joins because we have independent tables
that we don't receive in the same order
in which we are created so we cannot
possibly do any operation on that we can
only see an extra copy of the production
database
so we do a very simple real thing but
very powerful
which is we use materialized views so
in postgres but most relational
databases you can find a view which is
just a query with an alias so when you
need to query the same data again again
you can define a view and say okay
this long big query with joins and group
files and so on as an alias and you then
queried that alias instead of the actual
query which means it's nice for the
developers you don't have to see the
complexity so it's like a functioning
pattern you just call it and don't care
about the content but it doesn't do
anything for the performance it the
database is simply replacing your alias
with the actual view every time you run
it so it's not faster than just running
a bigger query it's just nicer to see
with a materializer view
you essentially ask the database to take
a snapshot of what you will see through
a query and store it as a physical table
so you can then apply indexes on the
table and accessing it is as fast as a
sensing any table
but of course it's a snapshot so you
have to refresh it manually so we just
use it
this is nothing
strange because you can do
many companies they do that and we can
have a chrome job on kubernetes or just
any
operation to refresh it
the thing that we learned is that if we
keep a naming convention so we can
associate any materializer view with a
corresponding view
we can then easily switch between views
and metaliser views and see the
performance between the
two usages and essentially it's much
easier to
sacrifice
when needed speed for
freshness so we can always decide
whether to use the view or the materials
view and it's very easy to compartment
then
okay we have a problem the problem is
that if we have applications that do a
lot of queries and wait a lot of time
performing queries
we have to monitor them and a problem
that everyone has at some point is the
speed of the application has to be
improved of course
and when that happens what many people
do and that's a big mistake that every
developers do
is instead of providing applications and
knowing how the application spends time
they just imagine something that they
decide it's the best way to optimize
think about tail recursion now at some
point it was like the hype and everyone
was doing the regression now
instead we want to know how the
application is actually spending time
for example how much does it take to run
a query on average you can always put a
query in a database client run it once
but that's not indicative of how much it
takes to run it on the actual loads
so our solution
is actually multiple steps the first
step is to have a sql file for each
query this is
simple and it's a very easy and
effective way to keep your query in
order so you don't have strings bars all
around all your applications you have
even worse functions that generate
pieces of query then you compose because
then you have no idea what you're
running
you have a folder with sql files and
every single file is a query
this makes a lot easier already to
monitor them you can easily see them you
can edit them you can do static analysis
so there are tools that can parse the
query and tell you which tables and
columns are being used so you can do a
lot of nice stuff automatically
but then it enables a few
nice things that we do
the first is that you can define
an helper
which is how we actually do queries so
whenever we want to run a query we
simply call this helper and say okay run
this query call it in this case get
relation popularity uh
the name will be getting popularity dot
sql we just omit it in the helper
and we pass the parameters so
this is already nice because you don't
have much code you just invoke the query
that way
but you can do a few fancy things the
first is that you can retry so if you
get an error like a network error or
database is down you just wait a few
seconds retry and then you have a sort
of
exponential back-off or whatever logic
you want to do
and this is how we can actually upgrade
the database so we have just a postgres
instance on rds we sometimes upgrade it
we pass from
posgus 30 to posca 40 and so on this is
a small uh downtime thanks to this
helper and the retro logic that is in it
we have no
our application keeps signing it just
waits and then keeps running
and essentially we never have to worry
about that
um when we run training or prediction
uh the second is that we can have some
transforming
uh this is a just nice thing to have so
if we get a pandas data frame
and since we have uh data frame that are
easily gigabyte of data big
we want to get the exact uh um
how to say
the number have to be in uh
unsigned integer or integer
specific format because that means the
difference that makes the difference
between crashing or not because we
consume all the memory
and then and this is actually
the point here
we can do profiling science with helper
is the only place when we run a query we
can always whenever run query see when
it starts when it ends and how many
times it was executed so we can easily
generate something like this you don't
have to read all the lines because
that's very specific the port of thing
is the
concept when you run a program you want
to go
you want to build a profile you want to
see how actually it is spending time and
by doing that by having a simple
simply
um a simple helper that invokes every
query that runs them we can easily
collect statistics and not on just one
execution manually but every single
execution in production and then we
easily build such a thing so a profile
that shows you
how the program is spending its time
across all the queries and potentially
every python
operation
and it's very
it's quite normal that you have a sort
of pareto distribution of the time so
your program spends eighty percent of
the time doing twenty percent of the
query so it's better to have this
information before optimizing
another advantage is that you can detect
in advance when a query is taking more
time because if you have a lock or a
table is growing a query can become
slower and slower and you want to detect
it before it starts loaded your program
crash you want to see it in advance so
you can use the data dog or new relic or
whatever and monitor this data in a
systematic way
this
was all about reading data which is fine
but then you need also to write data
because if you have create predictions
you have to write then somewhere uh we
rather than more kafka usually but also
on our database
so how do we do
millions of rows on insertions every day
in a decent uh fast way there are many
options
assuming you sql alchemy execute many is
probably bare minimum it opens a
transaction does a lot of inserts and
close the transaction which means it's
faster than doing
one row transaction of course
but still you can do better the best way
by far in postgres is the copy command
copy
essentially gets a csv of the data
and uploads it directly to a table is a
lot faster than every other option
um the problem is that it's very ugly if
you have json or data types that are
very complex to represent imagine for
example postgis and your geometries
and
also the interface is quite ugly with
psychopathy 2
you have to write question code and it's
not very
user friendly in case of errors
and in particular you cannot
you cannot
deal with abstract so if you insert data
you want to
deal with data that is already there and
you want to specify logic to merge this
data and copy cannot do that directly
what you can do instead
you can use unlocked tables and log a
table is a postgres
functionality that essentially creates a
table which is
sacrificing
how to say persistence so you lose the
table if database crashes so it's not
what you want usually
but is a lot faster to read and write it
can be easily two three times faster
when you re write it on a locker table
so you can copy inside and log a table
even through queries just merge it with
the final data that you have
then in psyc2 you also have the
very ugly functionality called execute
values
which essentially expects a template for
an update or insert
and it rolls the template replacing a
sort of percentage s that you write
yourself with the actual data so
basically it builds a huge query
by repeating values in the query
the problem is that
um it's a bit ugly to see and is
impossible to troubleshoot so basically
when you have an error you have no idea
which columns causes it you just have to
try until it works
but these in my measurements of course
that depends on your data
it was around 20 times faster than just
normal in sessions
and then
my favorite personal option is prepare
statements a prepared statement
allows you to send a query to a database
which can be very complex the database
compiles it and in the recent version of
postgres this happens through llvm so
it's very fast and then you just call
the handler for the compiler query by
passing parameters again again so
basically you can do a lot of in session
calling this inquiry again again
in a very effective way uh psychoph3 has
it as a sort
of first class function is already there
it's nice
and also psycho gp3 support the binary
protocol so it can communicate with
database not using text but
sort of by the presentation that is much
more efficient and compact
uh the problem is that psycho g3 is not
supported yet by sql alchemy sequencing
2 will support it but the carboxylic
activity doesn't and sql comma 2 is
still not available as a stable i think
not even beta
so that is the future probably but it's
not there you can do it psychology too
but it's ugly as well
and here i wrote an article about uh
comparison
of these methods and many more
and by the way i published a slide on
discord so you can access them
another trick
that we found is that we can simply
pre-process data once and store it as
file so when you do training you reread
the same data again again over time so
it's a bit stupid to redo the same query
to re-get the same data that is in the
past so not supposed to change the right
already parted the tickets already
bought so it's not different today from
tomorrow if it's right it was one year
ago
so what we do instead
we calculate this data day by day for
the past
and we get the result which is a huge
aggregation of everything that we need
as a file and we store it on stream or
any actually data storage
by doing that you have a huge
performance improvement i actually was
very surprised when i saw how fast this
can be
we run a comparison which could be a
torque by itself basically we run a
comparison of every format that we could
find
and we found out that parker and ro is
probably the best combination it's very
fast compressed a lot
and the support on pandas and spark is
amazing so essentially
parque
is a layout that allows for columnar
access so when you create a file or
multiple files representing representing
some data
you can later decide which columns you
want and you just read them so when you
read you can save a lot of time by
reading only what you need
arrow
is a bit hard to define but you can
imagine it as a sort of pickle across
language so you languages so you just
store your data using arrow
and you can read it back um without
thinking ah yeah i'm using numpy 120 and
i cannot read it because we'll speak
with no nothing like that you just read
and write from java to python to
whatever
it does actually a lot more
because it's also a way to represent
data in memory but we don't care about
that
and then we compress it with snappy but
that's just not the difference from
beta2
and most importantly
with pandas is super trivial to create
and to read and write
file in the small rod you just install a
pie arrow and you you have a meter like
save as arrow i don't remember name but
basically store
as r in this format and when you read it
back
um then
as anticipated we have the problem of
handling the schema changes
these can be done in many ways
one of the most common is to use equal
alchemy because it has a migration
functionality
sql image is an orm so you can
it assumes that you basically want to
use the ram functionality together with
the migration
which we don't use so
it's nice as long as you have
a format that plays well with the
oram
is not nice when you have for example uh
user roles and you have grants that we
do views you have some complex data
types
in the case you have to write them
manually and you basically defeat the
purpose of having sql argument then you
have sketch which is on the other end of
the spectrum sketch allows you to
uh define all the schema through
sql that you write manually and you can
also write
functions to check what is the state of
the database so you can just ask each to
check the sales database and apply
what's needed so it's extremely powerful
but you have to write a lot of stuff by
hand which
for us is overkill so what we do instead
is a very primitive approach we have a
repository a git repository with a
schema.sql file and that's it so it's a
schema you get an empty database you run
it and you get all the structures that
you need
then you have to of course the problem
of finding out what is the difference
with the database
so we have this uh monstrosity that is
actually much more simpler than it looks
with the our real mac file
and we use two simple tricks the first
is that there is a tool called pg
virtual lamp which can create a sort of
on-demand instance past the sentences
and so by doing that we can create an
empty instance and apply
our schema to type instance
then
we use pg dump which is just the
postgres default way to dump
a database with the option schema only
which only gives you the schema so by
applying pg dam schema only to our
ephemeral database created by pgw trends
and to the remote database that is what
we actually have
we get two schemas schematas depending
on what you want to use
and we can just do a textual diff it's
just text we have a huge global sequel
we just compare them and we can easily
very easily find out the differences
between the schematic production staging
and the desired schema so we avoid
having tables that are completely wide
and nobody knows how they
that they even exist
the final trick i mean the final for
what we can fit in a talk is to use a
postgre system table so podcast has a
lot of nice uh
tables that tells you everything about
what is happening in the base so
how much an index is used how much a
table has a sequential sequential
accesses so access data slow because
there is no index being used
blocks running queries and so on
and i can suggest this amazing website i
didn't do it i just found it which is
pgstats.dev
which has this chart of all the tables
across sessions and what they do and
which kind of data they show so it's
really an amazing resource
and the more you learn to use it the
more
black magic you can do with your podcast
instance
and
finally we are adding tends to cover it
now everyone has a qr reader on their
phone
and so if you
are interested in these kind of
technologies and
applied to a actual real problem which
we have a lot of data real data that we
apply to
a business relevant problem you can
apply and ask us we also have a stand on
the third floor so see
and so you can just reach out to us
if your questions this is a good time to
ask
[Applause]
so thank you thank you for the talk it
was very interesting i wonder if someone
has questions if you have questions you
raise your hand and i will run to you
and yes i don't see questions in is
little
but yeah we're gonna take offline
questions now
first thank you for this interesting
talk but i missed the part when you were
talking about cdc and coming the stream
of events coming from kafka and then you
jump to
using materialized view on bostigris is
it like you started to store the events
in bostigris and then to do the joins on
uh
from multiple streams yes so there is
this usually you have an etl and the etl
doesn't just copy data this but also
rearrange it in a way that is nicer for
you in our case for example we have
distances which are a bit tricky to
calculate
and because a distance can take multiple
countries and have different versions
but we don't care about it we just want
the distance
so with an etl you can have this
calculation down for you
but if we use kafka we get fresh data we
have a database in real time but we lose
that we cannot do any etl we just have
exactly what we have in the production
database
so we need some way to perform some sort
of mini tl on the fly and that's why we
use metallized view so basically
materials view replace
the operation that an etl would normally
do for you
okay so you are storing the events in
bostigris and and then doing the joins
in postgres but using better
materialized to improve the performance
of the joints yes so we don't store the
events as they are since every event
represents an insert update or delete
operation we redo the same operation on
our database so
we have an id and when we see that
something was updated on the
monolith database on the operational
database we apply the same update on our
database deletion and instruction are
the same then my question will be
oh okay last question okay last question
so uh is it possible to do this like any
using stream processing like not to
store it in boston and to do the joints
this is my question this is my
no you can do some string processing in
kafka but by the nature of kafka you can
always do with windows you cannot do
with all the data
and
on pause guess it opposite you always
see the world data and you have to
basically refresh the metallic view
every time
you can use partitioning do some magic
but that's essentially it thank you for
the question
does someone else has a question i want
to give opportunity to he's he's sorry
that'd be fast
how do you and the locks with the
migrations uh
stuff like that you say logs
we don't
well essentially when we
migrate we just we just know what we are
doing because that's the database i work
with every day
if i've logged either a weight because i
know that there is a prediction job that
is running and i want to touch it
otherwise there is a function which is
pg terminate speed so you can just ask
database to kill every connection and
you can just 10 minutes everything and
there are no locks
uh one question um so materialized views
they are supposed to be refreshed every
time you get new data
no
that depends on the application but
usually you either do a crown job so
every day at some point you just update
it or every week depending on your case
or if you want you can basically keep
track of what changed in the metallized
view so when there is an update
depending on how often the
changes and material is only on demand
that's another thing you can do
that depends on your application so you
basically decide how much to sacrifice
speed to access to get
fresh data
but aren't materialized views
constrained to only materializing the
whole data set wouldn't that be a bit
they just materialized a query so it's
like running a query and getting the
result into table
and you don't have to
apply them on a view so actually you can
apply them to a query that you run on
the fly
but it's in our case we just prefer to
have a view and a materials you based on
that like in that case
you can if you want to get all the
recent data you just put aware in the
query and you
just get whatever it comes out of that
does anyone else have questions
so otherwise i thank you a bigger plows
again for the talk